I know Legend Welcome to New York thank
you I love so glad you're here I man I
love it so much you're living on the
west side I know it's just everything
the energy everything is very much me
I'm very I do a lot you do a lot yeah
yes so that's New York too I know but
that's why I fit in yeah anything
special for Thanksgiving oh I gave up
Thanksgiving I cancelled somebody canel
nine guests cancelled because somebody
got sick oh no so so I decided I called
up my my chef friend and I said we're
not doing Thanksgiving yeah and I've
also cooked like 14 turkeys already for
my TV show you kind of done it yeah and
I still have to do one more turkey I
think on the Today's Show so a little
turkeyed out I am turkeyed out I hope
you have taco Thursday or something on
yeah just have we have tacos I'm going
no I made a plan U friends of of course
invited me to their home so I'm going to
about five different homes that taste
different courses you know do it oh my
God those friends must be so stressed
out oh I hope so yeah I was like if you
were coming to my house I would for sure
lie and say I cooked it and have
somebody else do it
[Music]
[Applause]
like thank you guys yall have a great
night
I'm going
home